[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen sven voss ist auch dabei für
den sport schon genannt und das sind
unsere themen hatte
deutliche worte aus berlin in
deutschland gibt es immer mehr kritik an
erdogan vorgehen im botschafter streit
verzweifeltes warten noch immer hoffen
afghanische ortskräfte auf ihre ausreise
und fürchten um ihre sicherheit und eine
wichtige stimme afrikas die autorin 17
dank arena erhält den friedenspreis des
deutschen buchhandels
dass der türkische präsident den
deutschen und neun andere botschafter
als unerwünschte personen bezeichnet
weil sie sich für einen menschenrechts
aktivisten eingesetzt haben das halten
die westlichen nato partner für einen
afro im moment beraten die betroffenen
staaten über eine angemessene reaktion
aus berlin kommt scharfe kritik nicole
diekmann
die gestrigen drohungen des türkischen
präsidenten heute das thema im
politischen berlin in der cdu hofft mal
auf ein rückruf an erdogan fordert
andernfalls aber eine gesamteuropäische
antwort
vielleicht kann man es noch abwenden
wenn nicht muss klar sein dass wenn er
sich entscheidet auf botschafter ebene
nicht mehr mit einer handvoll von
europäischen staaten und den usa
verkehren zu wollen dass das dann
dieselbe gegenreaktion von allen
mitgliedsstaaten der europäischen union
erfolge haben muss anlass für den eklat
osman kavala türkischer verleger und
regierungskritiker seit vier jahren im
gefängnis ohne urteil ihm werden
umsturzpläne und spionage vorgeworfen
ohne beweise 10 westliche botschafter
auch der deutsche forderten vergangene
woche kavala freilassen darauf reagiert
erdogan doch die fdp vermutet ein
ablenkungsmanöver des innenpolitisch
angeschlagenen türkischen präsidenten er
will provozieren und deswegen wir
sollten uns einfach nicht provozieren
lassen und nichts darauf eingehen das
deutsch türkische verhältnis
traditionell kompliziert aber man
braucht einander eine allianz die auch
die ampelkoalition beschäftigen wird so
sie denn kommt innerhalb der bundesbank
deutschland muss klar sein dass versuche
aus ankara die türkische community wie
das gerade geschieht in stellung zu
bringen gegen integration gegen
zusammenleben hier dass wir das nicht
zulassen werden das spd-geführte
auswärtige amt zurückhaltend aus dem
umfeld verlautet wir haben die
äußerungen des türkischen
staatspräsidenten erdogan sowie die
berichterstattung hierüber zur kenntnis
genommen und beraten uns derzeit
intensiv mit den neuen anderen
betroffenen ländern eine offizielle
mitteilung ist in berlin noch nicht
eingetroffen eine nächste
eskalationsstufe wird frühestens morgen
erwartet
innenminister seehofer will die
kontrollen im deutsch polnischen
grenzgebiet falls nötig weiter
verstärken das sagte er der bild am
sonntag schon jetzt sind 800 schafften
der bundespolizei vor ort um migranten
zu überprüfen die über belarus und polen
nach deutschland kommen in der nacht
griff die polizei auch rund 50
rechtsextremisten auf die patroullieren
wollten dazu hatte die rechtsextreme
partei der dritte weg aufgerufen
unter den geflüchteten sind auch
menschen aus afghanistan in ihrer heimat
warten noch so viele verzweifelt darauf
dass die bundesrepublik ihr versprechen
wahr macht und sie raus holt die
ehemaligen ortskräfte der bundeswehr sie
müssen permanent damit rechnen von den
islamisten entdeckt zu werden katrin
eigendorf
es ist eine provisorische unterkunft in
der sultan massu qassimi mit seinen drei
kindern und seiner frau liebt ein
versteck mitten in kabul
acht jahre lang hat er als übersetzer
für die bundeswehr in masar i scharif
gearbeitet obwohl er um seine sicherheit
fürchtet möchte er vor unserer kamera
reden ich habe angst ich fürchte mich
das
er kennt mich also in der öffentlichkeit
mein große befürchtung ist dass das
wegen man kinder findet was mit mir
passiert das alles hat sich verändert
hier frau war kann nicht mehr als
lehrerin arbeiten die elfjährige schafft
nicht mehr in die schule
smi hat bereits vor drei monaten einen
antrag gestellt nach deutschland
auszureisen die antwort sofort ihre
antrag bearbeitet ist werden sie weiter
informationen gehalten bis jetzt wollten
wir immer noch in ihrer heimatstadt
masar i scharif können sie nicht zurück
sie haben alles verkauft als sie vor
drei monaten nach kabul flohen in der
hoffnung nach deutschland evakuiert zu
werden wie so viele hatten auch sie es
nicht geschafft zum flughafen zu
gelangen wir wollen erwarten von der
durch bundesregierung das den
prozess
beschleunigen mit mehr als 100
anderenorts kräften hält es ihm in
kontakt sie wollen sich gegenseitig
informieren bis dahin bleibt nur worten
jetzt zu den aktuellen corona zahlen in
deutschland das robert koch institut
meldet 13
1732 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind 5000 50 mehr als vor einer
woche die sieben tage inzidenz steigt
weiter auf 106,3
bundesweit wächst offenbar das problem
mit unechten impf nachweisen die polizei
in münchen hat betrüger gefasst die
hunderte zertifikate gefälscht und im
internet verkauft haben seit august hat
in die bande qr codes für 350 euro pro
stück angeboten und allein im oktober
wohl mehr als 500 ausgestellt in
kolumbien ist der meistgesuchte
drogenboss des landes gefasst worden
dario antonius saga wurde im dschungel
nahe der grenze zu panama festgenommen
er ist chef des größten drogenkartells
von kolumbien das kokain tonnenweise vor
allem in die usa aber auch nach europa
schmuggeln soll außerdem werden ihm
morde an polizisten und soldaten
vorgeworfen sowie die systematische
ausbeutung von kindern
wenn ihr wollt dass euer leiden aufhört
müsst ihr handeln das sagt die
diesjährige friedenspreisträger des
deutschen buchhandels
zieht sie dann gar ender engagiert sich
seit vielen jahren für politische
veränderung in ihrer heimat simbabwe als
autorin als filmemacherin als bürgerin
heute wurde die 62 jährige in der
frankfurter paulskirche ausgezeichnet
peter wagner war dabei
zieht dann gar amber ist erst die
zwölfte frau die seit 1950 mit dem
friedenspreis ausgezeichnet wird die
laudatio auf die preisträgerin held
kazuma obama die halbschwester des
ehemaligen us-präsidenten und 17 gember
kennen sich seit gemeinsamen
studienzeiten in berlin ich denke ja
dass du manchmal am liebsten aufgegeben
cc der versuchen nachgegangen einfach
ein normales gewöhnliches leben zu
führen warum sich mühsam gehört schaffen
wenn man auch irgendwie so durch das
leben kommen könnte
du bist nicht gewöhnlich zieht sie die
preisträgerin spricht sich in ihrer
dankesrede für eine erneuerte aufklärung
aus für veränderte denkmuster
unsere entscheidung was und wie wir
denken ist letztlich eine entscheidung
zwischen gewalt oder frieden fördern den
inhalten und narrativen
als frankfurt sowie feldmann einen
anderen umgang mit rechten verlagen auf
der buchmesse fordert unterbricht die
grüne stadtverordnete man mit einem
engagierten appell gegen
allgegenwärtigen rassismus wenn wir
diesen menschenverachtenden ideologien
eine plattform hier in frankfurt in
meiner stadt in unserer stadt in meiner
heimat bekommt dann beteiligen wir uns
aktiv an den nächsten jahren auf eine
preisverleihung mit ungewöhnlichen
verlauf und der wichtigen botschaft das
schwarze stimmen gehör finden müssen
[Applaus]
ja mit der erste trainerentlassung der
laufenden saison nach acht sieglosen
pflichtspielen trennt sich fußball
bundesligist vfl wolfsburg von mark van
bommel der niederländer zeigte sich
enttäuscht und überrascht von der
entscheidung der vfl war mit vier siegen
in die saison gestartet und liegt
aktuell nur auf platz neun
es war ein torreiches rheinisches derby
im ersten sonntagsspiel schafft der
erste fc köln nach einem 0 2 rückstand
noch den 2 2-ausgleich gegen leverkusen
modell ist traf nach der pause doppelt
dieses thema geht über den fußball
hinaus die debatte um den nicht
geimpften nationalspieler josué kimmig
vom fc bayern polarisiert nach dem spiel
gegen hoffenheim hatte kimmig seine impf
bedenken geschildert
während in zahlreichen stadien die
zweijährige leyen geführt wird gibt ein
nationalspieler zu dass er noch nicht
geimpft ist
es geht einfach darum dass sich nur ein
paar bedenken habe deswegen ist es auch
sehr gut möglich dass ich mich in
zukunft impfen lasse auch in der
mannschaft ist der impfstatus von
chemisch ein heiß diskutiertes thema ist
zumindest die wissenschaftliche meinung
und auch meine meinung dass das impfen
besser wäre aber
gehen genauso muss man eben das
irgendwie auch versuchen zu respektieren
käme ich hatte bedenken wegen fehlender
langzeitstudien geäußert wir haben eine
sehr sehr gute datenlage und da es ist
eigentlich nichts außergewöhnliches ist
jetzt raus gekommen was uns verstecken
sollte und da wird auch nichts weiter
passieren insofern muss man eigentlich
nicht auf langzeitstudien warten er sei
kein impfgegner betonte kim ich als
profi fußballer hat er allerdings eine
besondere vorbildfunktion
silbermedaille für pauline schäfer betz
am schwebebalken bei der turn wm im
japanischen kitakyushu die chemnitzerin
schafft es an ihrem paradegerät bereits
zum dritten mal bei weltmeisterschaften
aufs podium
fahren rad weltmeisterin lea-sophie
friedrich hat zum abschluss der wm heute
ihre dritte goldmedaille geholt die 21
jährige gewann nach gold im team-sprint
und 500 meter zeitfahren auch noch im
keirin wettbewerb insgesamt war es die
erfolgreichste wm seit 30 jahren für das
deutsche bahn aktiv
herzlichen glückwunsch und hier ist was
vom spanischen der goldene herbst bleibt
uns noch ein bisschen erhalten im süden
am vormittag teils nebel im nordwesten
am nachmittag wolken und etwas regen
sonst scheint häufig die sonne bei 10
bis 19 grad
viertel vor zehn spricht man jetzt das
locker im heute journal mit
gesundheitsminister sparen danke für ihr
interesse wir wünschen ihnen noch einen
schönen sonntagabend und einen guten
start in die neue woche und empfehlen
jetzt stark unter laub energy und berlin
direkt